what was that I don't know but it
sounded like a hamster dying cool fishes
orgasm Anna are you feeling okay
great hey Anna if you're sick you should
go home and rest
I know I'm not sick though Anna there's
no shame in being sick technically I've
never not been sick doctors consider me
legally dead that's why you see so trim
yeah I'm dangerously frail it's uh just
allergies if you're sick the best place
for you to be his home in bed I can
power through Oh God enough Anna you're
gonna get all the snow
I had a headlights last February no one
even noticed that was you I have burned
most of my clothes
I can't take a sick day okay I already
scheduled all my sick days this year how
do you know when you're gonna be sick is
it crystals well you know my wife is
into like this alternative stuff
actually I don't know what I'm going to
get sick I work when I'm actually sick
so that I can use my sick days as extra
vacation days I'm gonna be coming down
with the flu
next month so I can go wine-tasting and
trench foot in September so I can see DJ
must meet in Vegas oh I love DJ Mouse me
I'm a mouse me a head I know what's
wrong I'm sorry Anna everyone does that
really think I have walking polio yeah
remember when I had pneumonia
I was kite surfing in Cabo with my wife
I've actually never been sick a day in
my life though I have the immune system
of a cat
did you know feline AIDS affects 5% of
all cats it's an epidemic nobody's
talking about it Elliot's trying to say
is it's okay to take a sick day when
you're actually sick you're right you're
right I'll go home I can just log Oh
Anna it's okay get in bed we'll cover
you it's not a big deal really
thanks guys 5% guys that's one in every
20 cats mr. Harris is at risk
he's a very promiscuous cat hey Sara
it's me yeah of course I bought it all
right I will see you in like 20 minutes
you are going to love the new bikini top
I bought okay all right Oh
I know so and I missed get it in the
basket please rose the germs
you